hey guys I'm Cleo I'm a producer here at
Vox and I'm also the host of box's
first-ever daily show
it's called answered it's on a new
streaming app called kwibi and every day
we take on a question about this
confusing moment that we're living
through so now I get to share with you
guys one of my favorite episodes so far
here we go
[Music]
by now you've probably heard of Nadia
the tiger but if not allow me to
introduce you to a tiger at a zoo in New
York has tested positive for coronavirus
researchers think that she caught it
from a human zookeeper at the zoo four
year old Nadia her sister Azul - Amir
Tigers and three lions all developed dry
coughs don't worry Nadia's doing a lot
better now but her illness highlighted
something about the virus itself it's
ZOA notic that means it can transmit
between humans and animals now the bond
between a Pomeranian and its owner may
have taken a serious turn the study
showed Winston the family's fun-loving
Pug contracted Koba 19 according to the
CDC and the US Department of Agriculture
two cats in separate parts of New York
tested positive Oh what this has me
wondering which animals can catch
coronavirus should I be worried about my
pet I'm Cleo Abram and this is answered
by box well for most animals that we've
seen that can be infected by covet 19
they don't have very serious symptoms
that's dr. William cherish
he's a wildlife veterinarian and an
expert on animals and pandemics I have a
dog should I be worried about my dog no
you should not be worried about your dog
dogs have been shown in rare cases to
pick up the virus but the virus doesn't
grow very well in dogs people found out
that dogs have it just out of curiosity
because the people in the homes were
very sick and they thought well let's
just just the dogs and see if they might
have it and they picked up the virus but
the dogs weren't sick cats seem to be
more susceptible and cats can actually
infect other cats but they don't get
very sick while it is possible for our
pets to get very mild cases of Koated 19
the CDC says quote the
of animals spreading kovat 19 to people
is considered to be low so it seems like
we can take our pets getting sick or
getting us sick off our list of worries
but it's clear that kovat 19 can
transmit between humans and animals so
researchers are trying to figure out
which animals are most susceptible once
the virus breaks into an animal's body
it needs to fit itself inside a special
receptor on the target cell called a Stu
the virus and receptor act kind of like
a lock and key the more easily the
Tsarskoe b2 virus latches on to a
species a Stu receptor the more likely
that animal is to become infected each
species a Stu receptor is a little bit
different so not all animals get
infected equally the virus is more
likely to bind in humans camels cats
penguins and fats but less likely in
rats mice chickens and guinea pigs so
this is the first part of the story
which which animals can it bind to but
it's not the whole story because we know
that pigs actually don't prove have a
productive infection even though they
can receive the virus which is why so
many animals are susceptible to the
virus but it doesn't make them sick we
don't want to jump to too many
conclusions but it's a beautiful start
to a way to look at susceptibility the
East to receptor is really only an
indicator of whether or not an animal
can become infected with coronavirus it
doesn't tell us anything about how
coronavirus can spread between humans
and animals I've heard people talk about
bats about penguins about wet markets so
I'm wondering what do we know for sure
about how kovat 19 got from animals to
humans well right now we don't know
where what the original animal source
was we know that there's many viruses
very similar to Co good 19 like all it's
kissing cousins and his brothers and
sisters we find those in bats many of
the viruses that make us sick originally
came from the animal kingdom the common
cold originated in camels many strains
of flu come from pigs and birds HIV
transferred to humans from a chimpanzee
Ebola SARS Marburg nipa and kovat 19
have all been linked to
Batz is there a specific reason why
these diseases come from bats as opposed
to other animals
there's over 1,400 types of bats so
there are a lot of viruses for one
things and then another is genetically
we're not so distantly related to that
either closer on the evolutionary tree
they're closer to people that a lot of
other animals are so the viruses of
course then it's easier to share viruses
with things you're related to like
humans and gorillas can share a lot more
viruses than anybody else why is it
though that when a virus like SARS Co v2
jumps from animals to people it's so
deadly to us whereas it's less so to the
original host animal all of us have
viruses and bacteria living on us and we
have grown used to them and over the
millennia we've actually evolved to use
them when we spread them among species
they have very different reactions over
the last hundred years the number of zoe
nautic diseases in people has been
increasing on average a new infectious
disease emerges in humans every four
months and 75% of them come from animals
zoonotic diseases have been around as
long as there have been people and
animals together what's new is what we
call these new emerging infectious
diseases and that's a new virus like
kovat 19 those are becoming more and
more common we have more exposure to
wildlife as we encroach into wild areas
as we disturb habitats they spread
faster because of air travel and trade
so the we live in a new world for now we
don't need to worry too much about the
animals in our lives getting sick from
Koba 19 but we should be worried about
health and our relationship with the
environment we need to detect these
things right away not wait until they
turn into a pandemic
[Music]
and that's our show thanks for watching
every episode is kind of like that it's
five to six minutes long it takes on a
question that's kind of in the
atmosphere right now and asks an expert
for the answers that might make living
through this moment just a little bit
easier so if you want to check it out
you can go to the link either up there
or in the description down there or you
can go in your phone and download kwibi
and search for box or answered I'll be
there every day